john for that update less than a week
there will be a flurry of activity by
resorts world
as it officially opens up surrounding
businesses super excited
there's hope that the north end of the
strip can really be revived and that's
where
madison kimbrough joining us live with
what the future of our neighborhood here
in the north end the strip may hold
visitors and locals can agree that the
north end of the strip needs some major
upgrades as you can see the attraction
of resorts world and increased
traffic changes could be on the horizon
for this portion of las vegas boulevard
it's not that that great compared to the
rest of it like you know
it needs a lot of work i guess they're
fixing it right but
it's not what you expect visitors to las
vegas have something to say when it
comes to the north end
of the strip it's like neglected area i
mean this is an area that looks like you
could really use the facelift
unlike the central and south portions of
the strip there's a definite gap
the north end of the strip has always
been the stepchild the big blue drew
sits vacant along with an empty lot of a
planned all-net arena
and a long walk to the sahara hotel john
delabose is on the winchester town
advisory board
he has seen this north strip struggle
but believes that could all change
the sahara has invested a significant
amount of money in
the lsls redo that they've pursued
and the allnet is going to be investing
a significant amount of money in the
vacant lot
that's between turnberry and the sahara
all that coupled with the large
investment done by resorts world
in my mind is really going to shift the
balance from
the south and the middle to the north
and visitors think this new addition is
sure to increase business for other
hotels too
it's going to be great to me like i
think it's going to make this area a lot
more popular you know it's going to make
more people want to stay in these hotels
in this this size i'm hoping it opens up
and brings more business into the area
which don't promote more businesses
building
maybe some newer buildings themselves
coming in
as for the construction here on the
north side there is more work to be done
but there will be
accommodations as the opening day of
resorts world is thursday june 24th
reporting live from the north end of the
strip madison kimbrough 8 news now